the alcs was on tv the other night
you've got a-rod and big poppy were on
fox sports discussing
the game
and the crowd
decided to start chanting a very
well-known expression a variation on the
phrase let's go brandon
guys can come in like a chest in the
queen or or a rook on the chessboard
right these people have routines but i
think if aldi is the one guy he can get
away with that evolving kind of let his
hair down a little bit he
threw most unbelievable split fingers
for strikeouts for out and two
when last diaz by the way missed
one calls tonight
right the average is eight or nine for
an umpire 21 is a great deal winning
that call i thought he lost his
concentration
and when he hung the split
kudos to a-rod for not breaking his
his commentary he keep pushing keeps
pushing right ahead but uh you can hear
and it's not let's go branded that
they're chanting it's the real the real
version of that
that took place outside fenway park
that took place it wasn't in south
carolina it wasn't in texas or tennessee
that was in boston
it's become a meme and also joe biden
has a very low approval rating even in
places that might have voted for him
i think the oppressed masses
yearning to be free
want political leaders to free us from
the shackles of this libertine woke
progressive liberal madness okay and i
think that politicians republicans who
run
on the old squish way of things i'm
thinking of asa hutchinson in arkansas
or you know any number of those wishes
who run and they say if you elect me i
won't do anything
i'll never impose my views on anybody
i'm going to defend the neutral or you
know the you know the neutral political
order of transgender bathrooms you know
the neutral political order of
completely redefining marriage you know
the neutral political order of this that
and the other thing
no i think what people recognize is
there is no neutral political order all
all polities have some view of what's
good and wrong and bad and
and we want our leaders to have a spine
okay we want them
to fight for us i'm so glad that you
enjoyed that clip i enjoyed it too i
enjoyed bringing it to you i'm glad that
you could listen and i could talk
sometimes people don't get the
notifications though that's a big
problem the way to fix that problem
ring the bell
subscribe
okay not just here hear me out
over at apple podcast spotify stitcher
google play aol instant messenger live
journal
xanga i don't know wherever man go
subscribe to the michael knull show
podcast leave a five-star review if you
wouldn't mind i'll see you next time
[Music]
you